depression is a serious mental illness
and I am NOT a doctor so if you are
clinically depressed get some
professional help but you don't need to
have clinical depression to feel like
crap once in a while in my life I feel
like I've lost my mojo like I've lost
that spark of life that used to drive me
to my goals and keep me motivated a lot
of people call this a funk and clearly a
lot of people find themselves in it
because when you type in on Google how
to get out of a funk is one of the top
results so how does one get out of this
funk well if you ask yourself that
question you came to the right video so
here are five scientifically proven ways
to unfuck yourself and get some positive
energized momentum back into your life
step 1
wake up at the same time every single
day you'll hear people saying all the
time that in order to be healthy you
need to get more sleep human beings tend
to operate best on between seven and a
half and eight and a half hours of sleep
but it's just as important to have
predictability in your sleep patterns
your brain needs that furthermore as far
as energy levels go your wake time is
more important than your bedtime your
body's internal clock loves a
predictable wake-up time so if you're in
a funk and you're serious about getting
out of it instead of saying I'm gonna go
to bed at 10:30 p.m. every night from
now on obviously try to go to bed at a
good hour but set a fixed wake-up time
that's non-negotiable and it'll help you
out a lot step number two is to go
outside in nature I make videos as a job
as my main source of income so you'll
often find me for hours on end days on
end in my little computer cave editing
away far away from the sunlight like a
little vampire boy and doing this makes
it very easy for me to slip into a funk
if I'm not careful but I've noticed that
going outside in nature taking a walk
getting some fresh air is integral to
maintaining my sanity and overall sense
of well-being in fact I made an entire
video about this the benefits of going
outside I think it was two videos ago so
I'll put a link in the description for
that video and check it out you'd be
surprised just how good going outside is
for you and most of these benefits I
talked about have nothing to do with
vitamin D go outside step number three
is to eat a good breakfast every more
I know that intermittent fasting is all
the rage right now with bodybuilders and
people who are trying to lose weight but
science shows that people who eat a good
breakfast full of omega-3 fatty acids
and protein showed elevated mood and
overall sense of well-being compared to
people who skip breakfast or just relied
on coffee and if you're not really a
breakfast person definitely do some
research as to what constitutes a good
breakfast like eggs and avocado and
things that will give you protein and
omega-3 fatty acids so then take a trip
to a grocery store come back with the
supplies and figure out how to make it
that way you're prepared there's no
guesswork you can just hop out of bed
have a good breakfast and be ready to go
tip number four is get some exercise
you've heard this a million times but
the science is there exercise is by far
one of the most effective ways to
alleviate depression and increase
overall mood because it raises the
serotonin levels in your brain the lack
of which is one of the main causes of
major depressive disorder
so if exercise is good enough for
legitimate doctors to prescribe to
patients who have clinical depression
it's good enough for me to prescribe to
you to get out of your funk and the
thing about exercise is you don't need
to develop a complex workout plan to get
the benefits studies have shown that
just a brisk walk for half an hour three
times a week is enough to give you the
benefits so even make it a daily habit
when you wake up in the morning set
aside 20 minutes to half an hour to just
put on some running shoes and walk
around the block I guarantee you that if
you're not getting exercise doing this
will make you feel a lot better and
finally tip number five is to get some
social interaction who would have
thought right studies have shown that
there's a huge difference between
quality face-to-face interaction and
just messaging somebody texting somebody
or talking to them on the phone long
story short face-to-face interaction is
better and makes you feel a lot better
too and an interesting thing is the
benefits of face-to-face interactions
seem to amplify the older you get so
even if you're young it's important to
develop healthy social habits so that
when you're older you won't be sad it's
not good it's not very it's not that
nice I don't want to be it sad old
person this may sound weird but I have a
very packed schedule most of the time so
I will literally schedule in a social
interaction into my Google Calendar to
make sure that I do it that way when I'm
feeling social or not which is usually
when I need social
interaction the most my fate is sealed I
I just have to hang out with somebody so
that's it if you find yourself in a bit
of a funk you might be in a bit of a
funk right now it doesn't have to last
forever and hopefully the tips in this
video will help you get that kick in the
butt you need to make you a productive
functioning human member of society
again if you like this video hit that
like button and if you like videos like
these hit that subscribe button follow
me on Twitter at better ideas TV and if
you're already subscribed make sure to
hit that Bell icon below the video so
that you don't miss my next video and
finally if you like what I do and want
to support the channel in the
description there's a link to my patreon
and even if you become a $1 patron it
makes a huge difference and helps me put
out videos like these in the future so
thank you very much thanks for watching
that's all for today and we'll catch you
in the next video